now that we know the full specs and
prices for the new redesign m2 macbook
air here are five mistakes that you
absolutely have to avoid when buying one
of these macbooks and my full buyer's
guide covering exactly which upgrades
and what configurations are best
depending on what you're going to be
doing so let's go ahead and jump right
in now the first one is make sure that
you actually need an m2 macbook air now
what i mean by this is that the m1
macbook air you can buy right now
is an amazing machine not only did it
beat out a lot of way more expensive
intel machines and it has a crazy amount
of power but you can buy one for way
less than the m2 version instead of 1200
you can pick one up as low as 850 brand
new on amazon or less than 800 bucks for
a refurbished one with a guarantee i've
used one for everything even photo and
video editing with 4k files and 50
megapixel raw images and it is great
it's great for travel the battery life
is fantastic and it works great for most
people so you can pick one up for way
less right now and save a ton of cash
now if you're set on buying this
redesigned model and you know that
you're willing to spend
1200 bucks instead of 800 you have to
know that you are not getting that full
performance that apple talked about on
stage you will need to spend 100 more to
get that new 10 core processor with that
performance boost that they showed off
apple gave a few figures on stage
including 25 better graphics performance
at the same wattage but that is
considering the 10 core model running
more efficiently to get the 35
improvement that is using the 10 cores
at more power this means that the 8 core
base model that you get for 1200
might not be much faster than the acor
m1 chip since we know that they are both
using the same 5 nanometer architecture
now if you want to see a full deep dive
into the m2 chip vadim is currently
working on that video so make sure to
subscribe down below which will also
help to us to reach our goal of 1
million subscribers we are so close and
we greatly appreciate it so if you've
been holding off to get a much more
powerful m2 chip in the redesigned
macbook air you will need to fork over
that extra cash and it's now a 1300
macbook now third is thinking that you
will get the full performance of that
chip on stage now we know that the m1
macbook air thermal throttled even with
the seven core graphics but the m2
redesigned version is much thinner
having 20 percent less volume even
though it actually has a slightly larger
footprint this reduction in volume is
because of the thinness and of course
the m2 macbook air is still fanless so
if the thicker 7 core m1 macbook air
lost performance because of throttling i
would expect the new thinner 10 core
model that puts out more heat to
throttle more now apple themselves show
off on their website that the m2 version
of the macbook pro actually has a bigger
gain than the m2 version of the macbook
air and they show small burst tests not
longer loads so there's a chance that
the 10 core will be barely faster than
the a core with extended tasks or even
similar in performance and that the m2
macbook pro could be much faster this
time because of its fan unless apple did
some magic with a large heat spreader of
course we will only know once we get
them and take the laptops apart like we
did with the m1 models as well as doing
extensive thermal testing and comparing
the macbook air to the macbook pro and
also the 8 core version compared to the
10 core version and real world tasks so
make sure you guys enable those
notifications down below if you guys
want to see those videos because we are
going to be ordering three of them the
next one is getting the base 30 watt
adapter apple showed off a brand new 35
watt compact usb charger that has dual
ports but what they didn't say is that
the 1200 macbook air still comes with
the same old 30 watt usb-c charger this
charger took nearly three hours to
charge the m1 macbook air and the m2
model has a larger battery this new one
has five more watts of power to make up
for that but what's nicer is that it not
only supports two devices and it's gonna
adjust power for the fastest charging
but is actually smaller and lighter than
the slower 30 watt old model apple
really should have included this and
ditched the old one but unless you are
getting the fifteen hundred dollar spec
you have to pay another twenty dollars
to get this compact dual charger or for
the same price you can get the single
port fast charger that has 67 watts this
will get you to 50 in 30 minutes instead
and charge pretty much twice as fast but
it is less convenient because it's
larger now the one reason some people
might still want to get the base model
is because that's the one that is most
kept in stock so you can also just buy
both adapters separately but they will
cost you almost 60 bucks so if you want
to get your new macbook air as fast as
possible you can actually just buy a
well-rated over 100 watt fast charger
with a cable for just over 30 bucks on
amazon or if you want a fast charger
that is actually smaller than apple's
compact one inker has their gan 2 for 50
bucks i'll link both down in the
description below number five is storage
do not think that you need to spend a
huge amount of money and pay apple's
prices for storage upgrades now i know
people are still disappointed it comes
with 256 gigs of storage that's not
enough for most but you have to spend
200 bucks to get 512 and up to 800 for
the 2 terabyte version now one thing you
have to know is these are not the ultra
fast ssds that come with the 14 and 16
inch macbook pros that go up to 7 400
megabytes a second these are the ones
that are pretty much half the speed so
instead of spending 800 bucks for a two
terabyte version
you can actually spend 360 dollars for a
sabrin's external hard drive that works
with thunderbolt or regular usb type-c
and you will get an additional two
terabytes whereas with apple you
actually don't gain two terabytes of
storage because the default already
comes with 256. so you have flexibility
with using this with many computers we
love these we have two of them they are
close to the speed of apple's ssds and
when you upgrade your system later you
could still have it i'll go ahead and
link that down below we highly recommend
those and i actually have a sixth one
for you and that is ram now most people
know that the ram is built in unless
you're coming from a long time ago or
maybe a windows laptop you only get what
you buy so if you just get the 8 gig
version that's it you're stuck with it
now with that the other mistake is
thinking that you need a huge amount of
ram these do come with 24 gig options
now so for 400 bucks you could upgrade
to that so some people will actually not
need to get any more ram they could
stick with the 8 gig model for example
we have two videos comparing 8 gig
versus 16 gig with the m1 the first
video of a d made where you're just
using a normal amount of tabs and you
just have one pro application open that
you're doing for productivity and in
there we see barely any difference in
performance the one time we saw a big
difference is for photo editing where
instead of taking three minutes with a
gig version it took two minutes and 43
seconds not really a big deal but if
you're somebody that likes to have 25
web browsing tabs open multiple
applications i have a super stress test
where we did 8 gig versus 16 and there
once the ram was maxed out instead of
taking 5 minutes for the 8 gig it took 2
minutes and 34 seconds now with that if
you're somebody that pushes your machine
for example ak video editing you want to
go extreme on a macbook air for some
reason now here we also see instead of
taking about 14 minutes it took about
six so that is a pretty good improvement
going up to 16 gigs so you really have
to be aware of what you're gonna be
doing with this system and how long
you're going to have it now some people
say buy the most you can buy because
you'll need more ram in the future
well with this unified memory actually
16 gigs performs more like 24 or 32 in
the past it's a lot more efficient
there's less duplication mac os is
actually more efficient so it's not
exactly true and apps have been
optimized as well and that brings me
into our buyer's guide portion if you
know that you want to buy the m2 macbook
air i would say that most people should
just buy the base model now let's go
ahead and go into that and we can base
our upgrades off of this one because you
don't have to go for the higher tier now
i will say that everybody should spend
the extra 20 bucks and either get the
dual charger that's 35 watts small or if
you want the faster charging go with the
larger brick that's well worth the money
unless you have to wait wait longer for
those options to ship in that case check
out the third party options that i
talked about now as far as the chip
right here we'll start with that
the only people that should upgrade to
the 10 core graphics ship are people
that are really going to push the
graphics for example if you know that
you're going to do a ton of video
editing if you know that you're going to
be trying to play games you want to max
out your graphics
those are the tasks that are going to
help for example 3d rendering that focus
on graphics you will see some
improvement now if you're somebody that
falls in this camp i would say wait
until we get our macbook airs we compare
the 8 core graphics to the 10 with
throttling and how much of a difference
that makes to see if it's worth it um i
think for most people the 8 core option
is going to be really good just like we
previously told people to buy the 7 core
version instead of the 8 core now as far
as the ram if you're just a student
you're doing simple web tasks email
youtube maybe some simple photo simple
4k video editing with short projects a
gigabyte will still do a good job
believe it or not i have the base
macbook air and i've done a ton of work
on it now if you're somebody who does a
lot of photo editing that is where the
16 gig model will definitely help you
will give you some improvements or if
you work on longer video projects and
i'm talking about 20 to 30 minute long
4k projects with multicam you will see
an improvement there as well
now for people that do coding if you use
logic you'll see an improvement but not
very much
now if you're somebody that does uh
instrumentals you do music production
with lots of plugins that is where the
16 gig can also help now as far as the
24 gig model almost nobody should be
getting this
unless you know that you want the
smallest and lightest macbook but you
also are going to use a ton of ram maybe
that's an option but in reality if
you're going to be pushing your machine
to this limit the macbook air isn't the
one that you want to get now as far as
storage the base one isn't enough for
most unless you use the cloud a lot like
i do in external drives in that case buy
sabrent and then get the base model just
for storing applications the 512 isn't
too bad for 200 bucks after that you're
really spending a ton of money just
getting a little bit of extra storage
and i say it would not be worth it i
think external storage is the way to go
and it's just really a luxury spending
these kind of prices to not have to plug
in an external drive and of course
remember the macbook air now can be
charged with magsafe and so you actually
have two ports available compared to
before you would you need to use one for
charging so there you guys go if you
have any other questions depending on
what you do just go ahead and ask me
down in the comment section below and
i'll do my best to answer your specific
use cases click that card above the
little circle to help us reach our goal
of 1 million subscribers and check out
one of those great videos right over
there this has been max and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
you